agradezco a jan hidalgo a yannick saturn
a valérie pécresse ya fabián hoss el que
desde esta noche me dieron su apoyo
[Aplausos]
solomont invitó de manera solemne a
nuestros conciudadanos cualquiera que
sea su sensibilidad y cualquiera que
haya sido su decisión en la primera
vuelta que se unan a nosotros
[Aplausos]
algunos lo harán para obstaculizar la
extrema derecha y soy plenamente
consciente de que esto no significará un
apoyo a mis proyectos y eso lo respeto
sé que esa es la decisión que ha tomado
por ejemplo son de melón son
[Aplausos]
pero aquí quiero agradecer su claridad
con respecto a la extrema derecha y para
obstaculizar el paso de la extrema
derecha
[Aplausos]
pero en este momento decisivo
para el futuro de la nación
nada deberá ser como antes por esto
deseo dar la mano
a todos aquellos que quieren trabajar
por francia
estoy dispuesto a inventar algo nuevo
para reunir todas las convicciones y
todas las sensibilidades
diversas con el fin de construir con
ellos una acción común al servicio de
nuestra nación para los años que vienen
a desear nosotros es nuestro deber
[Aplausos]
tú no competición a todos nuestros
compatriotas
que escogieron la vía de la abstención o
el voto extremo ya sea porque tienen
rabia frente a las desigualdades que
persisten frente a los desórdenes
ecológicos frente a la seguridad
cotidiana y a la dificultad de vivir
dignamente aún a pesar de trabajar duro
o bien porque se sienten
insuficientemente representados
escuchados o asociones a todos ellos
quiero convencerlos en los próximos días
de que nuestro proyecto responde de
manera mucho más sólida que el de la
extrema derecha a sus miedos y a los
retos del tiempo a los desafíos del
tiempo cuenten conmigo
[Aplausos]
porque no nos equivoquemos nada está
decidido y el debate que tendremos en
los próximos quince días es decisivo
para nuestro país y para europa
[Aplausos]
queremos una francia independiente
porque es fuerte
científico tecnológico económico militar
agrícola y culturales
queremos una francia que hable de pleno
empleo y que hable con seriedad y que es
capaz de financiar su estado providencia
nuestras pensiones nuestras escuelas
nuestros hospitales y nuestros servicios
públicos
queremos esa francia queremos una franja
que le haga frente al reto climático y
ecológico y mediante la energía nuclear
la energía renovable la seguridad
energética y la planificación ecológica
queremos una franja en una francia en
donde por la ecología las facturas de
calefacción van a ser más bajas
y las facturas eléctricas también
reemplazarán
el uso de la gasolina queremos una
francia justa para todo el territorio en
el error teniente y en ultramar queremos
una francia que frente a las crisis
actuales y porvenir seguirá confiando en
la ciencia de la razón en la competencia
como lo hemos hecho estos últimos meses
y estos últimos años
yo quiero una francia que lucha con
decisión contra el separatismo islamista
pero que a través de la laicidad le
permite a cada cual creer o no creer
ejercer sus respectivos cultos
[Aplausos]
y no quiero una francia que le impida
dos los hermanos a los judíos
comer como lo prescribe su religión eso
no eso no somos nosotros
yo quiero una francia
que lleve progreso a todos a nuestros
mayores a nuestros niños a los
trabajadores a las familias a las
mujeres y especialmente a las madres
cabeza de familia a los que viven en
precarias condiciones no quiero una
francia de la desregulación para todos
no eso no somos nosotros quiero una
francia que se inscriba en una europa
fuerte que siga ayudando alianzas con
las grandes democracias para defenderse
y no una francia que al salir de europa
sólo tendría como aliado la
internacional de los populistas y de los
xenófobos esos no somos nosotros
yo quiero una francia
fiel
quiero una trans una francia fiel al
humanismo al espíritu de la ilustración
al soplo de
1789 al aliento de
1789 esos son queridos compatriotas
queridos amigos y rivales los retos del
24 de abril esas son las decisiones que
con su voto
ustedes tendrán que hacer dentro de 15
días y quiero decirles esta noche que
empleare todas mis fuerzas para
convencer a cada uno de que el único
proyecto por el poder adquisitivo es el
nuestro
que el único proyecto creíble
contra la miseria es el nuestro contra
la vida cara es el nuestro que el único
proyecto de los trabajadores de todos
aquellos que están al borde del camino
es el nuestro
que el único proyecto de francia y de
europa es nuestro proyecto
creo en nosotros creo en todos nosotros
cualesquiera que sean nuestras historias
y los medios en los que vivimos todos
nosotros cualesquiera que sea nuestro
origen nuestros territorios todos
nosotros cualesquiera que sean nuestras
opiniones y nuestras creencias todos
nosotros eso es francia
[Aplausos]
entonces dentro de los próximos 15 días
no ahorraremos ningún esfuerzo porque
nada está decidido pero seamos humildes
determinados decididos salgamos a
convencer cada uno de nosotros el 24 de
abril próximo podemos escoger entre una
nueva época francesa y europea el 24 de
abril podemos escoger la esperanza del
24 de abril podemos escoger
la francia podemos escoger a francia y
europa unidas
viva la república y viva francia
el consumo
cuento con todos ustedes
[Aplausos]